welcome back ramos real estate the
sponsors of this next segment is taking
us on a tour of a local home that's on
the market and ready for your family and
friends
have you heard of summerlin south it's a
growing luxurious area for our growing
las vegas families but i'll let the
expert tell you more welcome to one of
my newest listings
10337 green amber drive this is jorge
ramos with evolve realty let's go inside
and check it out this home is like a
residential resort i mean come on the
moment you walk in this door you're like
wow you know floating staircase going up
such a grand entryway stacked stone to
the ceiling as you walk in it's open
living open floor plan with a luxury
kitchen here to the left you've got
these three massive doors you can open
up to have that great indoor outdoor
living two levels perfect for family and
friends and before we head upstairs if
you've got family in town this thing has
a fantastic layout full ensuite to the
left powder to the right as we head
upstairs there's three additional
bedrooms here with their own walk-in
closet nice loft you've got this massive
primary to the left double door entry a
luxury his and hers bath as you walk
into the fully finished closet at the
end now if you have kids they won't
complain about room size and parents you
won't complain about convenience the
secondary rooms are nice sized with
their own walk-in closet you got this
conveniently located
laundry room full lg appliances included
as you walk down the hallway here we've
got this fully updated
hall bath exposed hardware shower with
the large format tile very nicely done
another bedroom here to the right as we
walk out to this beautiful
covered balcony it's the indoor outdoor
flow for me with this huge covered patio
area you can see why this is the highly
desirable summerlin south area situated
next to this beautiful park amazing
mountains and a breathtaking las vegas
sunset views
this balcony also overlooks the backyard
decked out bar and grill area a
state-of-the-art pool and a casita yep
i'm sold
[Music]
i'm sold as well that place is gorgeous
thank you again to ramos real estate for
sponsoring this segment call
702-588-4800 or visit
ramosrealestate.com for more information
we'll bring